a modern experiential and perennialist
mystical framework
initially adi shankara about
1300 years ago or so
ended up consolidating a lot of the
frameworks around advaita vedanta
so meaning that knowledge
veda is not to
so meaning the quote
individuals and the ultimate
the absolute are one
they are not two that's what non-duality
means that this is the ultimate this
is the absolute this is the ineffable
and it's all
an appearance
which even as we've talked about on the
show quite a bit
the modern currents in
quantum mechanics and physics
are also showing that
the most underlying is
the modulations of energy which then
create the appearance of form of matter
and when you give a deep contemplation
to the infinite possibility space
of modulations of energy
similar to the infinite possibility
space of modulations of musical notes
or of art all of the different colors
on a palette that you recognize that
this
is just one
creation design out of
eternity out of infinity
this is one song this is one combination
on that color palette
one energetic modulation that appears as
form
and so adi shankara is one of my most
profound influences and
he was also one of the main
developers around the theory of maya
around the intoxication
of the illusion of the appearance itself
that draws
people to seek for happiness and peace
externally rather than the diamond
necklace around their neck
which is what happens in the parable of
the prodigal son with the turn
inward
and many of my modern
non-dual teachers like
rupert spyra
have learned from people like ramana
maharshi
who
was also one of the main teachers of
mine
who took the advaita framework
and drew the absolute
deepest contemplation to what's called
atma vichara
which is self-inquiry so it's to
contemplate
deeply on the i
ask yourself the question what is
i and that's why ramana maharshi said
that god
is the seer because once you contemplate
deeply enough on
i you contemplate deeply enough on
awareness you turn your attention inward
on awareness on consciousness itself
you recognize that that is a shared
amongst us all which is the pupil and
the iris is the unique coloration
and b that it's eternal
that awareness is eternally being
colored
by the experience of these dreamed
creation designs
and ramana maharshi was very adamant
about turning the attention
inward on eye on awareness
itself which then over time
would create more and more
of a gnostic individual that has pierced
the veil
to god realization
and so the
experiential side of the mystical
framework
is very deeply resonant and important
and it's very perennial
across the traditions because
turning attention inward is the key
because you recognize that awareness
is the key
and then there's the further
propagation of the
advaita framework into what has been
called the neo advaita framework the new
not to
framework and many people attribute this
to punja
and also the satsang movement in general
so the satsang being the gathering of
community
around spiritual truth and
the
both importance of the
direct recognition of the non-existence
of i or ego being a core
component of that and
as emerson said immediatism
the direct spiritual knowledge and power
that can be
attained and this goes back to platonism
as well and it also goes back to
the northern school of
zen that said sudden awakening whereas
the southern school of zen said gradual
awakening and that
ultimately it's both it's both gradual
and sudden
and the power of neo advaita in many
ways
is that it invites the direct
path it invites the
direct experiential recognition
and yet at the same time we recognize
that there is
trouble with this one direct step
because the mirror of consciousness god
is distorted slash polluted meaning that
if i'm a contracted
finite egoic separate entity and i
attend a satsang
where a neo-invited teacher says that
you are not real all of this is a dream
all of this is an appearance
the egoic finite separate entity
has a both
possibility of recognizing that
and immediately gaining more spiritual
power and recognition
and yet also the
potential of
the superficial spiritual bypassing
occurs because there's no dissolving of
the ego
and that's only what happens when
consciousness meditates on itself and
purifies
itself it makes the mirror
more clean and less dirty
so a dirty egoic separate entity
that is trying to recognize
the diamond necklace already around its
neck is very
possible and very helpful and yet at the
same time we must recognize that
the gradual meditation of the egoic
separate entity on its own awareness
enables it to have a more stable
process of going inward to that god
realization
and to even the absolute ineffable
because typically what's being
promulgated by the one direct step
neo advaita is the surrender to just the
appearance to the nothing to do
meaning that everything is
an appearance and the non-dual
is the unconditional freedom of the
um as in the
nerguna brahmin the brahmana without
attributes the absolute the ineffable
and then the saguna brahman the closest
we can try and add
qualities to the ineffable would be
something like
the unconditional freedom of that
expressing itself the
anarchic creativity of it
the exploration the leela the divine
play
and so there's both the
beauty of what neo advaita provides the
contracted egoic separate entity of
direct insight immediatism and yet at
the same time
the tailoring the simultaneity
with the process of being able to engage
with a unique
individuation that is turning inward
and helping the egoic contracted
finite energy relax
and release and expand itself into the
god rely state
and then into that absolute ineffable
and so we're gonna unpack that more
stable
two direct steps here in a bit but again
the key
insight here is that the in the non-dual
it would say there is no egoic
contracted finite entity
and then in the dualistic concession we
would say that
it's clear that there's a suffering and
there's an intoxication of maya that's
happening for
this individuation and that the
individuation is now
seeking inward for that peace and
happiness that is already the diamond
necklace around its neck
and so to be able to hold the
simultaneity of the non-dual
and the dualistic concession and the
individuation which is the artistic
expression of the infinite
is very important it's critical
and it's very much the ultimate truth is
the simultaneity across
all of those and that makes you very
much like joseph in the code of many
colors especially
when you're being a teacher
and helping those that are interested
navigate
the landscape of our metaphysics to be
able to successfully
turn inward and rise up that dualistic
concession of a mountain
to the absolute to the ineffable to the
dissolving of the sugar cube of the
contracted egoic finite entity into the
hot t of the infinite ocean
and that's why we say that
insight alone is not enough it's like a
gondola
ride it's like
here in the flat mountain which is one
of our
best artistic distillations
around the simultaneity of non-duality
and duality and individuality
simultaneously
and we've done an entire video on this
which you can watch on the channel
the idea is that neo advaita is very
much like
the gondola ride over there on the right
side
because the flatness is very much like
the non-duality and then the mountain is
like the dualistic concession where the
ego
is seeking the finding of enlightenment
of the absolute of the ineffable of god
realization
and that there's all of these paths and
all of these different signposts that
build up into this lattice work that
then enables them to pierce the veil
and to recognize their true nature
and that's what what that al-wujud means
the sufi metaphysic of the unity of all
finding because every single one of the
individuals
has their own unique conceptual lattice
work and their own unique style of
finding of piercing the veil and
remembering
which is what the greeks called an
amnesia
and so the gondola ride is very much
like neo advaita because it's like the
direct pointing
and it's great because it gets people to
ride up the gondola
and they get to the neoadvisor pointings
which happen in these sat songs
and then what happens is that because
the egoic contracted finite separate
entity never undergoes the dissolution
process
in the gondola it just comes right back
down to the bottom now it might come to
level one or level two instead of level
zero which is fantastic
but this is where we
undergo a process of recognizing that
we can actually tap into our ability to
be more like joseph in the code of many
colors
where we can both handle the neo advice
appointing like the gondola ride
but also we can help
those that are interested to recognize
the importance of committed practice
because that is what's needed to sever
slash destroy the not
forming identification between god self
and the finite egoic contracted mind
separate entity
and that's why buddha 2 500 years ago
underwent the process of the
depths of what now the theravada
buddhism
tradition lineage is the most
conservative teachings here
thanks to sn goenka and many others
that i've attended four times these 10
days silent
no talking no eye contact
and no technology meditation retreats
and what happens is that you really get
down to the roots
of misery
aversion and craving you get down to
those roots
and as you eradicate those roots because
you've attained a very high level of
sensitivity of subtlety because you've
trained via your respiration
that's the anapana that happens is that
you train via your respiration
to gain that intense subtlety and
sensitivity
and then you recognize that the monkey
mind is no longer
sending you around to aversion and
craving
but that in a sense what's happened is
that you've purified
your mind you've purified the mirror
you've purified
the awareness for you to be able to
actually
undergo the process of being equanimous
of being peace of being happiness and
joy
and being able to turn your attention
inward on that consciousness on
on that awareness itself to recognize
the sharedness the eternity of it
and the shunya the void the emptiness
also of it and that's why we go beyond
the emptiness and beyond
the everythingness when we talk about
the absolute the ineffable
and so that entire process is a
committed practice
it requires the ability to gain
the deepest subtleties and sensitivities
if you've been riding on the
elephant that's been drinking the
cocaine water
and is now you're the little rider on
top of the elephant
and the elephant's the monkey mind and
it's going absolutely nuts driving you
around you're the egoic contracted
finite entity seeking happiness and
peace externally in the intoxication of
maya
and you attend a satsang and this is
told to you
that if there's not a committed practice
that comes with it at the same time
that that
cocaine elephant is going to go absolute
continue going absolutely nuts
and so that's why it's called the not
and that's why there's a
process of a committed practice that
helps to sever slash destroy that knot
it in a sense it portals you away from
the finite contracted egoic mind into
awareness itself which is the first step
which we'll talk about here in a moment
but this committed practice prepares the
mind for insight into non-duality
so my last couple of years especially
where i've been going 100
hardcore full time on truth have made
me able to gain the satori that i got on
december 18 to actually pierce the veil
and that more and more people
undergoing a committed practice along
with the neo advaita
is what will enable more and more of
what al-wujud
those piercings of the veil to the unity
of all finding
to god realization to inevitable
absolute
ultimate realization and that's what
happens given the aphorisms the books
the quieting of the mind and retreats
is that when you actually undergo the
study of what tatvam asi
means you are that i am that we are that
or i and my father
are one from john 10 30. what happens is
that you
recognize the perennial mystic tradition
wisdom
and you also recognize more and more
that these aphorisms these books these
retreats these
yogas chittavrithi nirodha
as patanjali said that yoga or union
is the quieting of
the waves of consciousness
that the
different paths and signposts that that
are these aphorisms and books and
retreats
they add up in that conceptual lattice
work which then
enables the piercing of the veil the
wadat al-wujud the finding process to
actually
happen the an amnesia to actually
occur and so we have to remember this
it's like the synthesis of the neo
advaita
the direct path the satsang movement
with
the committed practices with the
aphorisms the meditation retreats the
books
because it gives us that better stronger
more robust lattice work that enables us
to actually pierce the veil
and it is very much like both the sudden
and the gradual awakening
and so here's what is more stable and
this was something also recently that
bentino masaro who's another main
teacher of mine
has been promulgating which is the two
direct
steps is more stable than the one direct
step
and so the idea is that the first step
is god realization
which is when the egoic contracted
finite separate entity
seizes seeking happiness and peace
externally in the intoxication of maya
and it turns inward like in the parable
of the prodigal son
on consciousness and awareness itself it
turns its attention on
the question what is i the self-inquiry
as ramanu maharshi said
atmavichara and so once that happens
the subtlety increases the sensitivity
increases from the gross
physicalism to the subtlety of awareness
of consciousness itself
and the more that we focus in our
attention
on the question what is i and the
self-inquiry process
we become aware of awareness itself
and then that is when we
recognize and realize that our awareness
is god
and it is shared amongst all 8 billion
of us in this creation design
and also it is eternal it is what's been
here being colored by experience it's
what's here now being colored by
experience and what's going to be here
in the future creation designs being
colored by experience
that awareness is the free agent of
the infinite of the absolute of the
ineffable
that is being colored by the experience
of these creation designs
that's the first step is that god
realization
and then the second step is the absolute
realization
which is when even you recognize the
each subtlety of the eternal awareness
itself
and then you pluck that last thorn
out and then that's going beyond
even eternal awareness to the ineffable
to the absolute to the ultimate
and that's when the recognition that
even eternal awareness itself
is a dream so it's not only the creation
design
is a dream but also the agent the
observer itself
is dreamed just like when you go to
sleep for a third of your life
and you simulate a dream where you
simulate both the observer and the
dreamed
landscape for the observer that is the
same as this
and so that's the second step is to the
realization of the absolute which is
even the observer itself is the last
thorn
which is dreamed and then that's what
opens up to the
absolute ineffable
and it all is the absolute ineffable
even those that are being intoxicated by
maya
are the absolute ineffable as well
because that's the uniqueness of the
creative expression of what this is
non-dual wise
and yet the dualistic concession is that
they are suffering
and that the turn inward is inevitable
and it's happening it's like the gps
callback mechanism of the absolute on
itself
to pierce the veil into god realize and
absolute realize
and so liberation already exists this is
unconditionally free
yet also will you realize this and
that's why in the sufi metaphysic
it says that only those that are
ignorant seek what is already there
like rumi said the diamond necklace that
is already around your neck
yet it remains for you to recognize it
it's already all unconditionally free
non-dual absolute ineffable yet
if you've recognized that you're seeking
happiness and peace externally in the
intoxication
of maya in conspicuous consumption and
greed
and materialism and fame and clout and
all of these things that you think will
give you happiness and peace
that inevitably
the turn inward is going to happen
because that's the recognition of the
diamond necklace
which is already peace and happiness
you will no longer seek peace and
happiness externally but you bring
your peace and happiness to everything
you do
you're not seeking it externally you're
bringing
peace and happiness to everything and
that was a beautiful teaching of rupert
spyra
and
rumi is in many ways goat the greatest
of all time because we go
around from room to room looking for the
diamond necklace that is around our neck
but then the addition that we've made
here on the program
to the diamond necklace is the indra's
net
is the net of being as the beautiful
illustration of alex gray also shows
where the source light is refracting
through each of our unique diamonds and
jewels
as a creative artistic expression
that's the iris around the pupil is the
unique creative expression
once we god realize once we go inward
here
as we say in the true simultaneity the
non-dual dual individuation
which we just did a show on that as well
which you can watch on the channel
that we go inward first to that god
realization
and that's what enables wu wei as lao
tzu said the effortless action
channeling the absolute highest morality
going
outward as the artistic expression
and all else is insanity
because it's a contracted finite
separate biological entity
that is seeking happiness and peace
externally
that is self dealing that is greedy that
is jealous
that thinks of itself as finite
and separate only
whereas the reality is when you go
inward and god realize
recognized absolutely ineffable you
recognize the pupil
and then that enables the perfection
that enables the
absolute highest morality to channel
through as you artistically
express yourself from the infinite out
rather than from the biological separate
finite
entity
and so that's where neo advaita
has been absolutely fantastic and super
insightful and i've adored it so much
and people like tony parsons and jim
newman and fred davis have been so
insightful
for me and yet simultaneously to
recognize
that there's a joseph in the code of
many colors
style of synthesis consciousness of
breadth and polymethy that is needed
to build out the conceptual lattice work
of all these paths and signposts
that then make it so that it can be
tailored like a jedi
to anybody that's coming in
word for the god realization
that's the true simultaneity the
non-dual dual individuation to be able
to navigate that space
like a jedi
and it's more stable the two direct
steps
than the one direct step
and yet it's one of the best
experiential and perennialist mystical
frameworks
it's the immediatism and it's fantastic
i hope that this has been insightful
this
video on neo advaita it's definitely
been one of the most profound influences
on my life
and i hope on yours as well i highly
encourage you to check out people like
tony parsons
and jim newman and fred davis and rupert
spyra and bentino massaro
and go and read some of the works of
ramana maharshi and adi shankara and
patanjali
and sri aurobindo and nisargata maharaja
and punja and sadhara meshwar maharaja
because these have very clearly
been swami vivekananda
the yogananda
most
clear transmissions of
the non-dual
nature of our
existence of our metaphysics
and yet
what we can do with the
communication of the non-dual is we can
also simultaneously be able to explain
like in the taijitu where you have the
non-dual monism
and you have the yin yang that are in a
rhythmic
balanced interchange like walter russell
said they're in a flux
ascension like a solenoid helically
towards a mathematical attractor that
our complex system is evolving towards
which is the oroboros godhead
and so to be able to synthesize even
that with electromagnetism and
with cyclic cosmology of people like sir
roger penrose
is going to be really critical for us
moving forward
and to be able to synthesize the
non-dual url
already at the diamond necklace around
your neck with the fact that there is
suffering and there are sustainable
development goals and there is a process
of
architecting and maximizing human
potential that exists simultaneously
in the ultimate all of that suffering
is a dream yet
at the same time it's also in this
creation design
something that we really are excited
about as the
iris the expression of the infinite of
being like that artistic palette
a creative expression that maximizes
abundance and prosperity
and that recognizes that the
individuation the individual
is beautiful it's the exact expression
of the infinite
that makes it so that the non-dual also
simultaneously is dual and is
multiplicity and that to respect
that is so profoundly important
because the same
non-dual teacher that is
talking about only non-duality and how
the individual is an illusion
is also potentially driving in the tesla
car
that was envisioned by elon musk
almost two decades ago and
was built by thousands of employees
and robotics and genius engineers and
scientists
that have made it so that the whole
planet can transition
to electric cars can transition
to more sustainable forms of energy and
so we have to recognize
that as well that appearance happening
in the dream as well and how it serves
us how it serves the social fabric and
that's what ramana maharshi meant by
sahaja samadhi
or buddha meant by the middle way
that in the tantric tradition you weave
your enlightened realizations into the
social fabric
so check out all of those
epic people that we listed and
also if the video brought you value give
it a like
subscribe if you haven't comment below
with your thoughts we'd love to hear
from you
and
share the video with people that you
feel like this would resonate with
and join the membership on the channel
if you'd like we have great exclusive
benefits there and every single dollar
that you put in goes directly into the
actualization of all of our big projects
so many great things on the roadmap here
in los angeles with animated series
anthologies
vr pedagogy so many good things
on the roadmap great
upcoming interviews with
awesome people out here that will be
turning their attention inward on these
topics which is going to be so awesome
and that's all infinite love absolute
adoration thank you so grateful
thank you
you